overture curtain slide
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what are we doing back in the rental
store alright so this is a video we're
doing I was just gonna do this video
with Brad because every time we meet up
one of the things we typically talk
about as we talk about Looney Tunes
cartoons because we love the shit out of
them and whenever we talk we just give
big laughs out of it and we kept saying
like we should do a video on this just
talking about our favorite Looney Tunes
memories and episodes and stuff like
that and you guys are hugely tunes fans
too so I figured like while we're here
just just talk about just talking about
some of our favorite moments and just
the stuff that made us laugh the hardest
your made us laugh as kids or even make
us laugh more now because that's why
mine with Looney Tunes like the more I
watch them like they do get funnier like
the more and even once I thought weren't
funny as kids will so maybe hilarious
now and one of the ones that pops in my
head that is like really grown to be one
of my favorites is this one they've done
a couple little red riding-hood one and
it has the purposefully worst actress
they've ever had in there it's this red
riding-hood that's supposed to say you
know hey grandma what big eyes you got
you come in and they constantly tried to
get rid of her and she keeps coming back
in getting her lines wrong and again
just as easily choose go big killer just
cuz you could get away with that
yeah and bugs is evil I can't eat myself
in the morning the red riding-hood one
that I saw more growing up was that
another Bugs Bunny one too it's the one
where it starts out being about the
Three Little Pigs I think but then
halfway through reading the blogs
yeah behalf way through bugs distracts
them by giving the wolf a copy a Little
Red Riding Hood and he's like oh wait a
minute I'm late I haven't even taken
care of Grandma and he goes he doesn't
even eat the grandma he just bursts in
but I love about that one - is there
going by the book and it's like what is
this book they they just know they have
to follow like why are you falling down
beside this is the book says the book
says the wolf takes a shortcut like well
okay and he takes a shortcut and it's
literally just a foot what was the
particular program that you were
watching were you watching like the Bugs
Bunny and Tweety show and ABC or
Nickelodeon hard or maybe just renting
the tapes or yeah I remember there being
a number of programs that you watch but
um because you'd seen the TV Guide we
usually show up as Looney Tunes I didn't
understand as a kid that these were
older cartoons like these were made back
in like geez 30s 40s and onward because
I just assumed no this was this current
show that was on and it's a show but
these were theatrical cartoons over the
money so a lot of times it had those
gags where they'd be like is there a
doctor in the audience and like a shadow
like a silhouette will come up yeah and
also like just that they were kind of
more geared for adults there's a whole
short where Daffy Duck is being chased
by the the man from the draft board yes
I was gonna get drafted into the war but
they don't really explain it I don't
think they go there just say oh it's the
man from the draft board and he's trying
to get away from the whole thing
mm-hm and as a kid I'm like what's
what's the draft board what's so
brilliant about that cartoon as well as
the first minute is if the news is
they're going to war he's like now we're
gonna go get a veteran he's so patriotic
then he gets a phone call saying that
the man for the tram ports gonna be
there
as soon as he figures out he's the one
that could die he's like nobody wants no
part oh he's going off the war he's
gonna get drafted I was like oh yeah I
guess he's gonna go to Desert Storm they
relish in the fact that kids no matter
what generation it is have morbid senses
of humor so like you know is there a
doctor in the house that you know that
that guy ends with just shooting the man
did that cartoons ends with him in hell
like there's the flames and everything
is like well at least the draft four
guys I'm gonna get my go to in my head
for just really dark jokes like that is
is the one where it's the the overweight
female rabbit going after Bugs Bunny she
sounds like Zsa Zsa Gabor and but she's
like let me give you a kiss he's like
close your eyes
so she puckers out her lips and buck
just grabs this goldfish out of the tank
next to him puts it over his lips she
kisses that he puts the goldfish back
cuts in the goldfish with a shock look
takes out a revolver goes in his castle
where bunches ever the bad guy he's the
antagonist is where he's racing the
turtle it's basically like the tourism
it's a tourist and there is the same
thing I think he just reads the title it
called you know tortoise beats Harry any
challenges into a race I think there's
three of them but each one is great and
it's so funny cuz it plays against type
where he's just he's the total jerk he's
cheating he's trying everything he can
to get ahead any time it backfires just
hearing Bugs Bunny crack and go insane
is the funniest thing
I always liked when bad things happen to
Bugs Bunny because usually yeah because
he's usually the one who's just like
Bugs Bunny's always got the upper hand
whenever you'd see Bugs Bunny like
particular is the one with the piano and
the mouse yeah it's like I always liked
when you saw Bugs Bunny getting taking
some shit for once
I love seeing Bugs Bunny just take
getting the the pitch taken out yeah he
was always the antagonist he's always
like I know opps Rick I'm like like oh
we're foots coming just hide underground
he's not gonna find you but he's not
even used as a jerk for a new all the
bad guys were just fun or anyway you
know even if you were to consider Daffy
here and there but like my favorite
characters gossamer was it the big yes a
big yeah yeah which is much like the
Muppets my favorite character sweetums
like I just like these giant hulking
like hey are you doing like and I just
like that character so much like that
bad guys were funner I like I like the
one where it ends with like he's got
bugs Andy's play how do you get a V it's
just like don't you know something's
watching us they're out there look in
the audience always on so you know
clearly I'd go and watch like SWAT cats
or something coming out like a few
things later and it doesn't with all the
other stuff they're doing in the 9 to 20
times of Tiny Toons which I really like
and spacejam and all that kind of I
never like sought it out it sought me
and that makes oh yeah well what's
everywhere because so many of them do
last for so long and what I like I like
we come across one that again you guys
grew up with like the singing frog right
yeah oh yeah so when I was a kid I I
knew what the joke was gonna be and I
thought what can't just get to the joke
but as an adult it's so much funnier now
and I'll see the exact moment where it
happens as you know he finds the frog
taking the talent agent can't get
anything tries to take it somewhere else
can't get anything it sees the theatre
and there's one shot that changes
everything
it's him and it happens really quick
it's him and his sort of crappy
apartment a goes under his mattress a
brings out this money he's been hiding
and he starts counting it so it's like
he's putting his life savings on the
line for this damn frog and suddenly
that as an adult element were suddenly
like this thing really is ruining his
life yeah yeah yeah we were right like
you know is singing frog and nobody
comes so free admittance so now he's not
gonna make any money on bees hoping
he'll catch on still nobody comes right
free beer so now he has to get beer he
has to buy beer for all these people so
they'll just see this frog so it'll make
him a millionaire and of course the Frog
stop singing exactly when the curtain
goes up and you just see his life
totally fall apart so they at the end he
puts it back where it wasn't in the
future somebody finds it they're like
ooh gonna make money you know it's gonna
ruin his life - yeah Looney Tunes
cartoons were very depressing fables
yeah you really like the sad life lovely
jarred like it didn't talk down to the
audience like it knew like people
watching this they loved having a sick
sense of humor especially kids they were
was like cerebral or anything but like a
lot of them definitely made you think
especially a lot of the one-offs were
it's like the house of the future and
they really kind of like rip it on 50
Society in one of the ones you know
there's a lot of classic coyote
Roadrunner ones but the one that I don't
remember which one it is but it's
something where he like gotta try and
rope the roadrunner he gets hooked onto
a car truck and okay well that'd be
beyond the joke but the truck keeps
going and he runs and all these are cars
and he's hitting these cliffs and they
get caught on like another rock and that
swings around hitting all these in and
it goes on for like a solid couple
minutes and finally at the end you know
he lay it puts him back where he was
somehow he lands right memories got all
these stars and he's just there and
again he never talks or anything he just
goes totally it's the only time you hear
the coyote like karai and like you said
it's so morbid and that's like so
depressing but it's so yeah when they
crack my favorite woman of all time is a
duck rabbit duck yeah though with the
winter one the winter one
yeah with Elmer Fudd and Bugs Bunny and
Daffy Duck it's the
like mangu season elephants see like all
like if he's a duck then I'm an elk and
bugs holds up elk season awesome that
one just when it ends with Daffy just
crap he's been shot in the head just
crash at Elmer and oh we're just looking
so dumb like just not know like he
thinks he's doing what this duck is
trying to do which why is he listening
to the duck anyway and there's just
there's so many levels of like do you
root for Daffy do you not root for him
or even the coyote it's like well who's
the villain in the coyote rum runner
who's the hero you know it's hard to say
cuz you do kind of want him to win you
wanted to get the roadrunner but you
also kind of like the roadrunner so
there's something was not always black
and white yes in the road because
sometimes you're not even sure if the
roadrunner really even knows the coyote
he seems oblivious everything but like
yeah because it's not really like Bugs
Bunny where it's oh it's the roadrunner
that's like messing up his traps or you
know really you're causing all this
chaos - it really is this the coyote
fucking himself over life and the Acme
company like there's some times where
the roadrunner is like you know looking
at him and fucking with them a little
bit but a lot of times it is like the
Tramp fails yeah yeah yeah like it says
the roadrunner even know he's here kind
of like you know the whole point is like
the best mate plans might still fall
apart yeah up in your face like you
don't like anything like like you watch
a Mickey Mouse cartoon you like like oh
what time that was fun but one time a
fourth of July got some firecrackers
Mike and I he was like a few years ago I
think I think Mike bought them for me at
an ACME store he's like Mike do you know
what you just did you just bought
fireworks at Acme buck Rockets you just
fucked as a kid that there's a grocery
store Acme but there is like fictional
Acme and that's like why would they
colleague with
a lot of companies back that it's
account lives a very generic name Oh
wasn't Acme corporation it still is you
still see Acme names around
I liked on the VHS as they would have
Sylvester best bucks might and then
they'll have the best of Chuck Jones the
best of Freleng and you'd see like the
different styles and the different types
that they would have so and I know it's
the best ones the most the ones I almost
felt emotional towards we're always the
Chuck Jones one yeah that was always
like the what's opera doc yeah I mean
that wasn't even that one and as you say
with bugs essentially dying and it
looked beautiful I mean just the shots
were it introduced so many of us to
classic music and vogner and stuff like
yeah rabbit of Seville did the same
thing yeah it's a Mozart yes I mean and
he just did cuz he liked that music but
so many kids are introduced you know to
this classical music I mean this great
music the last four years through Bugs
Bunny yeah I would rent those tapes too
because what we would watch on Saturday
morning was always like the Bugs Bunny
and Tweety show but that would edit him
edited them down a lot not not because
something like date had happened and um
or something like that but more so I
don't know if it was for time or what
but like duck rabbit duck they butchered
yeah you couldn't tell what was going on
they would thought out the gunshots
where his beak was going it was insane
so we would rent them there like it's
like okay well this is one of my
favorite one so I'm got this tape now
for duck rabbit duck but then also like
the movies they did that combined new
footage with old footage so like they've
linked them in a plot and you could tell
when the new footage would happen
because bugs would like it still be Mel
Blanc but bugs would have a Mel Blanc
after like 10 cigars boys like it would
go into the old footage words obviously
recorded 30 years anyone that works with
me should never get me riled
why not because I'm a personality you
bring up like Tweety
I hate Tweety I know
Tweety sucks I remember just in the 90s
they were just everywhere like someone
have a t-shirt yeah
[Laughter]
the bunny Snatchers was that the one
where the animation gets worse as
they're like taken over or weird or yeah
yeah like this so the these aliens come
and replace the Looney Tunes with these
fakes but the way they're fake is that
they're animation is suddenly terrible
he's talking there's literally a human
mouth saying like you're despicable over
yes and it was the first time I ever saw
that effect done were like a human mouth
and I was just like whoa this is weird
I feel like this was probably put out in
the 90s like yeah the TV oh I remember
when I saw it come on it was part of
like another block of other shorts
whatever but when I saw it I was just so
fascinated because it was basically
invasion of the body snatchers but with
Bugs Bunny where it starts off and they
just do their normal routines like with
you somebody Sam and Daffy but it's Bugs
Bunny going to each these characters but
then he when he the next day when he
goes back to them these alien parents
were like left around and then they be
replaced
he's like hey are we gonna like argue
and everything and Daffy's like no it
doesn't matter anymore bugs and they're
just like now they're all like his
friend and he's like well this is weird
like what's what's going on here and
then it's like bugs starting to go crazy
that everybody else is like not
themselves and it's I really like that
one it was clever is actually especially
for a later Looney Tunes cartoon it was
like legitimately close creepy it was
like yeah I'm getting like goosebumps
the kid I'm watching I'm like wow this
is it's pretty funny
when it would get to like that era is
when I'd be more fascinated by things
that they were changing like okay there
was there's one from 40s or 50s where
it's
bugs and Yosemite Sam on a train and
it's got the bid at the end there's
Yosemite Sam throws Bugs Bunny into an
oven and bugs is pretending there's a
party going on in it come on they need
chips in there it comes back out they
need some like party poppers goes back
in and then he tricks Sam and to go in
there but then bugs looks in himself and
there actually is like this Old West
cabaret party like a live-action footage
and when they when they put that one
back out in the late 70s they changed
that to where like it was then suddenly
a disco so like there's this disco music
playing and they look in it's like
studio 54 and you hear Sam go what a
party just doing blow any war all right
now another one that was like you know
you have we're talking about the
cuteness with like Lady Bird I don't
count with you I never really got into
those but there's one do Jersey the one
with the cute little kitten and the
giant Bulldog yeah and again they are
when you think about them they're
surprisingly dark because he comes
across this little kitten and and he
doesn't know if the woman the house is
gonna let him keep it so he tries to
hide him in like this cookie mix and she
starts to make cookies and the cat gets
out but he thinks the cats in there so
he's just watching this thing get mashed
and cut up and closer you see him
watching these like fainting and he's
like you know passing out and there's
one point where he just like he's like
biting his lip and
one point you only see like one eye
walking in the sweat pouring and he's
crying up a storm and is something that
and then he goes in and like the one
that's just like you know oh don't you
look sad here this will cheer you up and
gives him a cookie of a cat that looks
just like I think I finally figured it
out liked all the Looney Tunes stuff is
like what is that German where like
shine and John Troy is like you get that
like you take enjoyment from watching
the misery of other oh yeah but but but
then it's clutch but then what's so
clever about is you know he's got the
little kooky and he's crying and the
kitten comes up and you know meows and
he perks up and he's so happy and so
many people have said that said they cry
at that cartoon because they
so sad to see that connection at the dog
has with this little kid even though
there's no talking or anything but they
get that connection and they feel when
he's sad for the kid and they feel
really happy when they're reunited again
at the end so I mean even just these
little shorts where there's no talking
they can really really make a connection
you mentioned Tweety Bird too I'm kind
of like you guys he wasn't my favorite
but there's one that is birds anonymous
do you remember yeah you're talking
about getting into some like dark
subject matter Birds Anonymous is one
where like it was the first time as a
kid where I learned what drug addiction
and rehab worse because Sylvester the
cat is addicted to trying to get Tweety
Bird and you try to kill him and eat him
and then these other cats approach him
and tell him that he has an addiction
and he needs help so he goes to the bird
eating version of a so he gets up and
speaks my name is Sylvester the cat hi
Sylvester you know like it's all of that
and then he just starts going through
heavy withdrawals like it's like a ton
of cigarettes cigarettes sleep can't
sleep blood it's like Trainspotting were
like he's like boarded up in his room
and like he's like trying not to relapse
and like the other cat is like shooting
a plunger over his mouth it's like I had
a feeling you were weakening it's crazy
I was telling my wife about this the
other day and she's like she's like oh
yeah I remember that one she said the
same thing like like I thought that was
so much like what I first figured out
what they would get in bed like ya know
what's so great on one of the lane toons
DVDs they said there were people that
you know that weren't worth with AAA and
stuff like that and said this is
actually very positive
material because Sylvester is always
trying and even at the end like the
other cat like he kisses the bird and
though he gets hungry for him and tries
to get him and Sylvester stops that's
good now that's a funny joke but it's
also very much showing he's made
progress and he's like actually trying
and he's the person was saying they're
like ya know they actually really
capture what's like to go through
withdrawal staying up and just being
like you know through the night like not
being able to sleep you know with the
bird the other cats like his sponsor
yeah
it's almost like like the animators
themselves are putting you in their
world with actor uh Paul lately
doing all these sketch yeah they're all
kind of smoking all the time to kind of
alcoholic you're always on edge the
Looney Tunes just felt way more adult
than they were a said that when they
drew them they do them for themselves
cut because especially when they start
out they didn't care what they drew
isn't made of money the guy Leon
Fleisher yeah yeah was just like and
just do do what you want man as long as
it turns into profit you know just let
them go off and that's how they caught
on the Disney one artistically they're
very pleasing is sometimes you get an
emotional one but but with Looney Tunes
you'll it's kind of you'll always get
what's funny and then sometimes you'll
get a real artistic one to you know that
I'm like really nice backgrounds and did
just some amazing drawings and stuff
like that they're like very abstract and
totally different from Disney you know
the best backgrounds from Warner
Brothers never looked like the best from
Disney you know they were much more
abstract and strange and had these great
angles and curves and stuff like that
did you guys ever see the a gal forget
the name of it but where Bugs Bunny is
conducting he's fucking with an opera
singer whose name is Giovanni Joey comes
interested as Leopold back then everyone
is so impressed that Leopold is there
they let him do whatever he wants
and so the opera singer who like tried
you know like broke his banjo and stuff
like he treated him bad so he's getting
revenge and again all the orchestra and
the singer and everything they're just
gonna do whatever Leopold does so he
just goes like this just because of his
stamina and who he is he is 100% his
slave like he would just sing whatever
he does
[Music]
until he finally just holds his hand up
yeah it doesn't bring it down just to
see how long he'll go I don't even know
how conducting actually works my dad was
in the Navy but it's exactly like that
like you know where you just you keep
the beat like that I mean it's usually
for time yeah but I mean but you can
kind of do whatever you want pitch like
do they actually do it for a while no
see that what makes even funny oh the
boys would be in the lower the with them
just like to see if he notices so again
it's like the great thing about that
cartoonist was he'll he'll leave the
hand up to see how long he'll do this
one note and then he'll leave the glove
up there and he'll leave to get
headphones to pluck out because that's
loud which is already such a dick move
but then like in the longer versions
you'll see him write the note put it in
the mailbox wait for it to arrive give
the package and you know that he's still
singing in you could see him in the
background a couple of times like his
face is like black and red like his
closes snapped off it all comes
crumbling down
he gets up still boughs that's really
funny and then there's a rock hanging
and once again he goes like this and he
still sings to have the rock fall on him
so even after all that mayhem he will
still do whatever he's always antagonize
he has to be brought into yeah someone
has to fuck with him first typically
more often than not yeah one of my
favorite memories was actually really
really because yeah you and I will text
each other Looney Tunes quotes all the
time my wife and I were at the mall
recently we were over at Hallmark and
they had a bunch of like Looney Tunes
ornaments and one of them was from
devil-may-care
the one where bug sends the Tasmanian
Devil away at the end I think that was
it he he orders them like this
mail-order Tasmanian Devil Brian who
comes in by plane just start yelling at
each other in boggs dresses
like a priest and he he marries the bull
and he's like so I got a picture this
ornament that was that scene from it
sent it to him I just quoted that part
of and just killed my autocorrect what I
like too is when suddenly the Tasmanian
devil would just speak perfect beautiful
English like wife or did you what for
you bury me in the cold cold ground the
whole thing was like another thing I was
like lost to me as a kid cause I just
like thinking I was like is the is the
ground cold missing the joke
what did confuse me the most when I was
a kid was when something racist would
happen and one of them because like what
because we're in the eighties like
sometimes something like that would
still be in there and whenever it did
happen I never knew what it meant I
never knew what it was yeah like they
get blown up and they have the black
face that was black face back then and
we had no idea what I just thought they
were blown up and that was it like this
very specific design whenever they get
blown off you know it must be said that
as much as these cartoons or hilarious
they did a lot of things in bad taste ya
know what I like a lot of these elite
uns DVDs now they they open up with
Whoopi Goldberg coming out and giving
this really awesome speech saying look
these are being kept intact
this is wrong then it's wrong now but
editing it like this stuff shouldn't
exist is acting like it didn't and we
can't forget this existing you know this
should never be forgotten so these are
left to not repeat it yeah yeah yeah I
think that was even one of the phrasing
I thought I was just like well done
silly she's great I love her yeah I'm
not that really nailed it so I guess you
just want to end with like favorite
moment or something like that yeah
okay my favorite moment it's an easy one
I think it's really every time you see
the shot of the the coyote falling and
it's that aerial shot or he's just a
shrinking dot because like they could
have done I mean as a kid I loved that
so much because I'd never seen anything
like that I'm like they could have just
showed him falling the kind of falling
down but instead they show how
insignificant he is it's all in the
background to me it's just so mad it's
like oh you know sometimes they show the
aftermath where he like lands and he
gets flattened like a pancake or
whatever but just like that shot when
you it's like you just have this big
like all this scenery and it's like it's
just like nature doesn't care like no
matter what is going on in the scene
it's like so small and insignificant
it's just it's beautiful I mean I heard
you say favor from Looney Tunes I guess
overall I think you know if I can dig in
the tiny tunes of it I really love like
the movie that how I felt like summer
vacation is great there's a lot of fun
little horror cliches a lot of cool
stuff in that one you know cuz I run the
you know the ironic and row space Jim
was really good and I loved all the
classics I've especially this stuff
about voices which just goes to show how
great they were at animation and meeting
timing and the voice you just added a
lot more to it but yeah probably the
tiny turn stuff was really good I'll
just say all of what's opera doc I think
is that turn me on to vogner I love
magner and that's what got me into it
and it's also a beautiful cartoon and
the backgrounds are amazing it's also
funny it's notable as hell okay that all
that I mean it's just one of those works
like the whole thing is just so grand
and it's like even like even though it's
a joke at the end that he's dead it is
expecting an eye for a happy ending it's
still sad because it's that amazing
music and the backgrounds and stuff tell
you so much they surprisingly give you a
lot of emotion it's in such a small
amount of time so it's just that whole
car - and I say it's probably the one
gag that gets me every time that I'm
just in tears when this happens wily
coyote going after Bugs Bunny where the
the wily coyote super genius one where
he talks when he talks it's like I
love uh this isn't alluding to the
tomandjerry I love when Tom for some
reason whenever the coyote talked I was
like oh it's one of those living off
when that would happen in Roadrunner but
with Bugs Bunny I didn't mind it when he
did like I liked all the super genius
stuff and there's one gag it gets me
every time it's where he builds this
little saucer think that is it's
supposed to fly to a certain animal
that's just on this little dial that it
has like you just flip the switch over
to rabbit and so it'll fly after a
rabbit and then explode so it flies out
of the Coyotes cave Bugs Bunny sees it
coming and his rabbit always like yikes
he gets out he comes back of me as a
rooster mascot and it stops it stops in
front of them and when it's not looking
bugs just writes the word coyote on it
it was the one to gag of writing on the
saucer to make it kill the coyote and
pet rooster bass really like anything
Marvin the Martian oh yes my favorite
gag was always the black hole into I
wish we had was put on the back here
just like green screen and open who
wants to do that any movie that's not
say one last thing on that just in their
favorite mode cuz we didn't talk about
Marvin the Martian marching that much oh
there's one where it's like he has the
dog and just one of the ways he gets out
of bugs - out of the situations that he
calls Marvin the Martian over just
there's the dog you say doc don't you
know about that guy and he just whispers
something - you have no idea what it is
it's just from the dogs point of you
just looking it's likewise even going
along with this ain't just wispy - and
Marvin Martian just turns around and you
have no idea what he said but he
distrust that dog beyond anything and
it's one of those things where it's just
left totally ambiguous what he's a me
just know he hates that you know dog
right yeah
I do remember that shot he's like he's
right there from he's like so obviously
like whispering and like he's talking
about yeah guys that's about it thank
you so much for just yapping Louie tunes
with me like I said and yeah they went
out there the unseen I'm watching
they're so good revisit them they're so
so good as much as I love them I think I
like Tom and Jerry even more I was
introducing him to Tom and Jerry before
we came here so yeah so check Tom and
Jerry too late James without talkin true
P yes shouting out Tom and Jerry like go
check out it nobody knows them leave
this channel guys thank you so much take
care my mate that's all folks
[Laughter]
you